also freunde das ist jetzt das weiß die
erste runde von challenge accepted hätte
leute kehlen können bin gut ausgerüstet
aber ich bin unter der map das ist halt
so das problem
hey freuen und herzlich willkommen zur
ersten folge von challenge accepted ich
sage euch gleich mal die challenge
moment die werdet ist wahrscheinlich
jetzt schon sehen
los gehts und zwar darf ich nur nach
rechts und links laufen das hat mir
willy wonka 50 geschrieben und ich
versuche nun so ein wenig zu überleben
alter das ist echt schwierig vor allem
weil ich einfach nicht gucken kann was
was rechts von mir sicht hoffe ich weiß
nicht ob da hinten kiste ist also ich
darf nur nach rechts und links laufen
das heißt muss die ganze zeit jetzt
irgendwie so laufen und wenn ich mich
irgendwo hingucken will muss sich quasi
kann ich eigentlich in lauffen und
hingucken sondern ich muss
dementsprechend hat sich löschen weil
ich diesmal kurz das tier dann bin ich
nicht so arg überbelichtet und zwar muss
ich jetzt immer dahin laufen ja man hat
nicht hisste mein gott ich habe schon
mal einigermaßen gute sachen
wenn ich das irgendwann nicht beachtet
dann tut mir das leid aber das ist dann
einfach so gewohnt dass man halt nicht
nur nach rechts und links läuft sondern
vielleicht auch meiner vorne oder mal
nach unten hinten genau hin habe ich
gesucht und ich versuche jetzt einfach
mal so ein bisschen hier zu überleben
kämpfen kann ich dann halt auch nicht so
richtig also ich kann keine vorschläge
machen mitzusprinten uns am kap sowohl
auf den ersten nicht auf daran glaube
ich wo ist conny ich hasse das wenn ich
auf server und desktop werde dazu habe
ich schon video gemacht nein keiner
kommt dass einem kein wind
die abda
hdf nämlich auf nein weißt du ich spiele
einfach nur suchen an dem es hier
nein also nochmal ihren alle die das
gestern nicht gesehen um erste folge
hier links und so hatte ich die man doch
da gehe ich hin
erste folge challenge accepted das wird
immer eine runde seien die kammer zehn
sekunden gehen
er kann auch mal sein das okay man ist
einmal eine minute und verwundbar wie
kann man zehn minuten gehen den sekunden
gehen die kammer den minuten gehen kommt
darauf an wie lange ich halt überleben
es gibt nämlich dann so sachen dass ihr
mir das in die kommentare schreiben
könnt da waren ja schon
nein da waren ja schon 2000 kommentare
glaube ich nein ich mich wieder runter
gefallen
ich will nicht immer die w taste drücken
ohren einmal ganz kurz dahinter das hat
keinen unterschied ja brustpanzer kommt
zu papa so eine kiste ist also ihr könnt
mir einfach in die kommentare schreiben
zum beispiel jaja weddings mach mal so
und so hier macht man nur 11 5 und sowas
oder macht man nur mit opti fallen
zoomen und zur ganzen mist das ist die
ganze zeit so rumlaufen das auch schon
krass eigentlich das könnt ihr mir in
die kommentare schreiben einfach da
unten da ist diese kommentare dingsbums
box da könnt ihr das einfach da könnte
es rein schreiben und dann werde ich da
eventuell darauf zurückkommen und das
dann eventuell machen und ich versuche
nun so lange es geht zu überleben
das ist das ziel das ziel ist nicht zu
gewinnen und das ziel ist einfach ein
bisschen spaß zu bereiten dass ihr so
sehen können hey guck mal wie macht er
das denn also ich kann dann auch immer
so patrick sie greifen zum beispiel hier
können jetzt einfach fünf aktivieren
damit ich ein bisschen mehr sehe
natürlich klug kann ich auch einfach
machen und zwar der willy wonka einfach
nur geschrieben gabler macht man nur
rechts links laufen und ich habe auch
nur de und are
da bekam auch schon eine sache an die
auch sehr geil ist ich werde dann immer
noch auf ein paar ältere kommentare zu
greifen das heißt wenn ihr beim ersten
kommentar geschrieben habe und danach
wehrte youtube kanal liegen gesperrt
kein plan
ihr könnt jedenfalls keine kommentare
mehr schreiben kann es immer noch sein
dass ich den trotzdem nehme weil ich
auch ja mann war ich dann natürlich auch
auf die anderen sachen eingehen werde
auf die anderen kommentar ich bin
komplett ausgerüstet die habe beschwert
welche runde gewinnen sollten endlich
bitte alle pvp pro hängen wir einfach
nur noch an nagel und dann passt das
rundum gespielt und ganz anders borg ist
voll wenig dahin gucke wie verlogen und
jetzt wow das ist echt krass ich gucke
mir im schnee einfach nur in der kamera
so sind die noch im wert da unten gehe
ich jetzt auch mal rein ihr leben
dennoch sechs leute team nein ich mache
nicht tinas interview gesagt mach
einfach mit allen leuten team die em wie
siehst das ist sehr witzige runde wie
jetzt dann geht das ja hier klasse macht
da das effektivste menschen sind schrott
ich glaub's nicht mami fahrpreisen
schwert ja okay dann bestimmt schon
welche irgendwie diamant sachen oder
irgend sowas
das coole sie kann auch nicht sprinten
das heißt essen bringt rein gar nichts
und jeder der mich sieht der wird mir
denken dass mit dem schief gelaufen
ich werde einfach überhaupt kein risiko
gehen ich versuche jetzt einfach erstmal
zu trinken oder dass wir natürlich
fabio wartet auf mich wollte mit dem
fifa spiel ich möchte doch ein bisschen
action dass er langweilig denn rumlaufe
das ist ja nicht bloß so also erstmal
tschuldigung das gestern kein video kam
tut mir echt leid was schönes wetter war
gar nicht zu hause ich bin was war dein
gestern gestern war
ach ja gestern montag ihr wollt ihr
immer so ein bisschen wie halo kann was
bei dir so passiert ja alten fall ich
mal rein
haye hat wehgetan er gestern war ja
montag da war ich erst in der schule bis
15 30 und dann war ich rücken und
trizeps trainieren und danach bin ich
gerade unter der map
wenn ich unter der map bände dass das
ganze wieder so enden musste das sich
unter dem web verschimmelt das war
genauso wie mit simon letztens ich komme
nie mehr raus
ich bin gefangen ich bin gefangen
ich bin wirklich gefangen ja ich muss
jetzt quasi auf dessen verhalten aber es
gibt bei ghom hd.de carouge nicht obwohl
ich kann versuchen hier vorne hoch zu
laufen nicht ranzig mit einfach nur l
und er also nach links und rechts so
hier kann ich ja mal versuchen will muss
auch noch mit links und rechts runter
gefallen ist
hier geht es nicht mehr weiter guckt da
warte ich beweis euch dagegen nicht
weiter ich bin ich bin 9
ich bin eingesperrt und ehre und der map
genervt dass man damit die sehen das ist
ganz meine kulig haben youtube ja cool
hat eine doppelte gerissene ja in szene
dass eingestellt
nein also change accepted schreibt
einfach in die kommentare
wenn ihr mal ja mach doch mal hier nur
fünf oder mach ich das vielleicht also
in fünf wäre dann ja so als ich zeige
euch das mal ganz gut so und dann kann
ich jetzt so normal rumlaufen finde ich
angenehm als dieser scheiß den ich jetzt
hier gerade mache also besser als hier
einfach so herrschen ja das ist kacke
wenn ich einfach unter der web in komm
ich verarsche ist auch schön die leute
habt ihr shirt und alles aber bin leider
unter
traurig ja ich kann schreiben ohne dass
hingucker ist man mit der zeit
warum nicht jetzt so wie es ja das ist
wirklich mies das nochmal und nochmal
ganz tief runter gefallen also freunde
das ist jetzt das weiß die erste runde
von challenge accepted hätte leute
kehlen können bin gut ausgerüstet aber
ich bin unter den web das ist halt so
das problem ja nebag sera lee von und
jetzt kommen zieht kommunen komme das
kommunizierte wieder mit meinen freunden
ja ist aber gerne aufnahme wäre jetzt
einfach lief mache schreibt in die
kommentare ob das game
nein also ich sag jetzt erst mal so es
war die wir verhängen konnten 15 kleinen
dingen deswegen wird es langsam dunkel
also schreibt in die kommentare wenn ihr
irgendwelche challenges haben wollt wie
zb nur 11 51 empfindlichkeit auch ganz
hoch
keine ahnung das ist eure sache ihr
könnt euch da irgendwas einfallen lassen
was ich machen soll dann mache ich das
gut das war jetzt eine relative viel
runder hated alle gomez hat spaß soll
was an sich ganz cool aber dass ein
paket mit passiert ist berührt naja
jedenfalls schreibt keine sachen in die
kommentare wenn ihr wollt und dann sehen
wir uns bei der nächsten testrunde
eventuell auch mein halo schreibt mir
kommt are very low voltage daumen hoch
gehen lassen und sie nur drei übrig
verlasst mal alle dann gewinne macht
na gut da hinten ist ein weg na ja ich
würde euch einfach ich würde einfach
sagen gebt dem video dann hoch wenn ihr
demnächst relativ schnell dingsbums 50
weg hier
wie viele sp haste 90 ich weiß nicht was
sp ist das steht nur rechts am rand zwei
zweifel provinz genau schreibt gibt
enorm hoch wenn ihr mehr challenge
accepted haben wollte und dann werde ich
mich da zu bemühen dass das irgendwie
reißen kann
komm gib an kleinen dingen waren bei
eventuell hier sieht aus als könnte ich
hier hoch laufen
ich probiere das mal eben
ab
hopp
ob
hopp hopp hopp
ok weiter geht nicht freunde es war ein
schönes leben mit euch
ich dachte ich sterbe mit zum coolen
abgang
na gut dann lebe ich jetzt tue leider
habe ich jetzt leider ein paar beulen
tierpark gammelt dafür ich weiß nicht
dass etwas gezogen jedenfalls würde ich
mich bei den bewertungen freuen ihr
könnt mir weiterhin challenges bzw wenn
ich du wäre würde ich blablabla machen
in die kommentare schreiben und dann
gehen